hello and welcome to zero playing agent
Fox Mulder so that last game was a bit
of a disaster so i hope i can win
against the agent I've got a completely
perfect record against 50 so how that is
an indicator of things to come yeah I'm
playing this this gambit line I don't
know it well but I always feel it sir
it's so it looks dangerous how to do it
here not g5 maybe I am just making up
things here over the board I don't know
what the bestest
okay what now Bishop d3 I know f5s
probably around the corner anyway
mmm Oh Bishop d3 should be three is also
an option I know you will play at 5i
guess I don't want to move it again okay
it's not spent too much time
ok
I don't think I had time for um for big
prep moves so what is this we should f8
is coming so probably 95 and I Knight f6
hmm seems it doesn't work
yeah I don't know probably that wasn't a
very threatening sacrifice and going for
him I can push fy5
yeah f5 is still still somewhat
interesting so I'm not sure that it is a
super easy win for black at least see 5
+ f5 mmm-hmm it's not an easy victory I
think I mean at least at least I don't
see something that is like winning super
easily for black
hmm yeah it's it takes this time there
yeah i'm i was expecting this a little
bit but anyway now who p1 that pressure
on f7 is quite something I mean I have a
piece down but all pieces that I have
are attacking so
hmm I'm not sure I don't really see how
he defends it it looks very dangerous
yes maybe that one
so takes root ly one maybe
I think kicks and rupee 194 Bishop f7
king of Ed Queen f7 looks like winning
yeah I thought queen age 7 and Bishop of
seven wins maybe I'm wrong check check
and Bishop Epsilon I thought and maybe
you can take with the Queen oh that
might be possible but I can also take if
one takes night night if for takes rook
checks but ok first of all Bishop takes
Bishop f 7 25 Queen check kini 7 you
might hope that he might hold it ok
maybe I have to take f7 and just go for
the attack there should be six though
and if i take this snow i was planning
on Bashar sm ready it doesn't seem to
work this is a threatening 95 for Queen
g8 but I think there should be six is
the problem
i'm not sure that i haven't moved after
that a good one maybe takes a 95 now we
can take that hmm wow that's bad 95 you
can't capture now g5 we can take that
sets that stupid tie morning it's really
really awful so where do I go night h8
it looks completely bonkers let's do it
still not easy and I think
maybe Knight f6 started defense
Jake's i mated mar 23 country I shoot
check please place even better you can
take that actually doesn't want to write
a check I'm really playing stupidly very
a stupid way in the skin and I will open
this on time for all you check check
check check my glorious it up when your
turn my check draw checkered ok check
check and I'm video one time I don't
know for once check black for inside
yeah but twice actually but I don't
resign I don't like that I don't want to
give away too many points and at least a
draw yeah ok this this attack should
work objectively I think the engine
gives it as a draw that's funny this
position ok let's see exactly those
moves it gives and now our now look f3
is actually going to an advantage hook
at 3g three okay but I'm curious about
this because I thought
very logical Bishop g7 is the best move
and now what does the engine want to
play to get this draw Bishop chicks and
back yeah that makes a lot of sense
actually it now wants to check and go
back and claims that I don't have a
better move than King g1 this is cool so
what about this and the test that black
defense personnel hmm honey this is
stronger than probably what I played 94
is it strong I object I relied on Bishop
f7 and only now saw that you can
actually take this and this is just a
check just simply I'm running out of
ideas sim and this was the big problem
no I'm just in problems taking this
giant I'm fishing now just being worse
and I just six is a draw yeah of course
it's a draw why did they do that I
simply didn't see it Rukia this is a
mistake you know I can have this one and
let's draw no I assembly didn't see it
he could have played Queen III that's
why I expected just trade queens but
Chad of course it's his continuation is
also good and now I'm losing him on
position at least timewise its equal I
simply don't I don't want to give up
there I mean everybody just plays on
time every damn position and I mean I
tend to offer draws in those situations
where we are meeting on time
I don't know what boom I'm not quite
sure if this is making any sense or not
but I don't feel like I should should
simply resign those those positions ok
anyway thanks for watching